Hi! I'm Jeremy, a Consumer Experience Specialist at Google.
Today, I'm gonna talk to you about malicious software also known as malware...
...and how you can protect your computer from infection.
First, let's talk about how you get malware.
Malware is often installed on your computer without your knowledge when you visit certain websites.
Sometimes, these are good sites that have been compromised by malware creators.
And other times, they're simply bad sites built to distribute malicious software.
Malware may also be installed when you download a file that appears to be legitimate,...
...but is actually doing things that you didn't want or expect it to do.
Malware has been known to do things like delete data on your computer,...
...steal personal information such as credit card numbers and passwords,...
...send spam email, or even attack other networks and computers.
One of the most common symptoms of malware that our users report...